look
[Music]
hello how are you greets go wonderful
with the headlines for today Tuesday
October 27 the newest verse in downtown
is preparing for its premiere tonight it
comes up it cost a billion dollars and
this is the first verse in this
hotel zone in 40  years one of the sections
that attracts the most attention is the pool
on the roof which is popularly
named as web stations it also
has 30 cabins and a space for
4000 people
the president tram will travel tonight to
las vegas later he will visit buffet ser y
persona  tomorrow he has a
campaign event planned at noon at the
love link international airport yesterday
on the other hand the
democratic vice presidential candidate as the xerez will be
visiting nothing he will do today his
campaign team announced that he will have a stop in
las vegas and then in the ring  or
to encourage residents to participate
in early voting and now we pass
with the weather forecast we will have
a maximum of 68 degrees  two with some
breezes for the valley however
as of tomorrow sunny days are expected
rolling 70 degrees
have an excellent day I am I came out
Jaramillo and this was your brief
disney news in Spanish
[Music]